this video is sponsored by Squarespace
it seems like every guy wants to get
massive traps these days upper traps
specifically so they can get that yoked
look this makes you look massive even
when you're wearing clothes but I
believe that form should follow function
the best way to train your traps to look
massive is to make sure they perform
well with that in mind I'm going to
recommend an exercise that I think can
do wonders for building massive traps
that also function extremely well and I
think this could be the missing piece of
the puzzle for a lot of people but it's
not one I hear recommended very often
first though I'm going to tell you a
story that illustrates just why this is
so fundamental so as some of you might
know I've been struggling a bit with a
slight lower back pain lately so I
finally decided to see a chiropractor
and get some advice from someone it
wasn't so close to the situation who can
actually look at me back there and see
what's going on what they also said to
me when I was lying down on the table
for the first time is you lift your
children with your left arm don't you
and I said how can you know that from
looking at my back and they said because
the traps on that side were so much more
developed than the traps on my right
hand side my son's about 12 kilograms of
daughters like 17 kilograms they're
basically like kettlebells that I'm
carrying around multiple times
throughout the day all the time and this
confirmed to me two things first of all
what I've always said that what you do
inside the gym is just a really small
piece of the equation what's more
important is what you do outside the gym
your way of life because an hour's worth
of gym is not going to make up for
however many hours worth of doing
everything else throughout the day even
though I train my trap specifically in
the gym you could still see that
lopsidedness because of all that
incidental training and at the same time
also reaffirm through what I've also
thought which is that the traps are
primarily carrying muscles they're for
carrying stuff and using this
information I found an exercise that I
highly recommend so what am I
recommending that you have kids just so
you can walk around with them because
that's totally not what I did what if
you don't have kids and don't want kids
should you borrow someone else's kids
should you just find some kids in the
street no do not find kids in the street
and use them as weights but there's an
exercise that you can use to emulate
this and I'll get to that in just a
moment first we need to talk about the
different functions of your traps
because you can actually divide the
traps into three parts you have your
upper traps you have your middle traps
and you have your lower traps nice and
easy to remember the upper traps are for
shrugging for elevating your scapula so
if you don't know the answer to a
question that's your upper traps your
middle traps are for retracting your
scapula pinching them behind you
backwards like so and finally your lower
traps before depressing the scapula
pushing them down towards the ground so
if you really do know and you definitely
don't want to shrug so to start with how
do we train the upper traps this is what
most people want to focus on to get that
yolked look so with everything we've
just spoken about in mind the exercise
I'm going to recommend you might have
already guessed it's your friend of mine
it's the loaded carry or Farmer's walk
simply here you're going to grab one or
two weights in one or both hands and
then just gonna go for a walk you should
be here maintaining a slight elevation
of the scapula so you don't want your
shoulders to just hang under the weight
you do want a little bit of shoulder
stability a little bit of control you're
just going to slightly shrug the
shoulders up then go for a walk and
after not long you're going to feel your
grip burning you're going to feel it in
your core potentially but you're also
going to feel it in those traps of
course this doesn't have any range of
motion it's a isometric hold for the
traps but over time you're going to feel
that metabolic build up and this will
translate to bigger thicker traps
and if you want to be a complete nutcase
about this and take it to the next level
if you want to emulate that incidental
type training where you're training
throughout the day without even trying
then you can even do this around your
house throughout the day keep your
kettlebell with you and simply make the
rule that you're going to carry it to
every room that you move to so if you go
to the bathroom you carry the Kettlebell
put it down do your business pick it up
and carry it back to where you were if
you go up the stairs you're carrying it
with you now recognize that this isn't
super practical for a lot of people and
that most people aren't going to do it
but if you want to go that extra mile
and you want to see some crazy results
for your traps I recommend you just give
it a go but that still doesn't perfectly
emulate carrying a child because when
you carry a child the position is
slightly different and I think this is
actually key in training the traps
properly because when I'm carrying my
kids I'm not just lifting them up I'm
also pulling them into my body to keep
them stable and safe and to do that I
need to engage the middle traps as well
and bring my shoulder blades back and
pinch them behind me also my biceps
because I'm curling them in towards me
and the tool you can use the most
closely emulate this is a sandbag
sandbag carries involve clutching the
bag towards you with all your strength
pulling in towards you and up at the
same time and then walking and this is a
great way to build those traps and get
that Dad strength for real do you want
to focus on bringing your traps back
behind you shrugging them up slightly
and squeezing it at the same time then
go for your walk
it just makes a ton of sense to me to
think of the traps as carrying muscles
because primarily the traps are for
shoulder stabilization for moving the
scapula around and if that's all they're
for why do they need to be so strong and
so big the answer of course is that when
you're carrying something you need a lot
of stabilization to combat that weight
fighting against you train them as they
are intended to be used and you're going
to see great results
of course this also makes the traps
fantastic as picking up muscles which is
why movements like the deadlift are also
so fantastic for training the traps as a
secondary benefit anytime you pick
something up off the ground and walk
with it you're training your traps even
without thinking about it of course
there are lots of other great exercises
for training your traps but I'm going to
take you to my local calisthenics Park
trim Trail in order to discuss those and
demonstrate some of those movements so
if the traps are carrying muscles first
and foremost I'd say they're probably
climbing muscles as a secondary function
this is because when you're climbing you
might think of using your lats to pull
yourself up you're also actually pulling
yourself in towards the wall so that
your center of gravity is closer to the
wall at least this is what you should be
doing if you want to climb efficiently
and it's especially true when you're
traversing moving sideways so rock
climbing actually a fantastic way to
build the traps at the same time Soto is
performing a lot of calisthenics
movements such as the arched pull-up
you're going to perform a pull-up as
usual but instead of having your body in
a straight vertical position you're
going to arch your back so that you're
trying to bring the sternum up to the
bar this is very hard to do so that way
if you can't perform the full range of
motion to begin with you'll get there
eventually but you want to focus on
bringing the scapula back and pinching
them behind you together using the mid
traps to do so this is a fantastic and
functional way to train those traps if
you find that a little bit difficult
then an alternative is the inverted
push-up or the bodyweight row you're
going to hang under a bar a pair of bars
and pull your body weight up but you're
going to keep your feet your heels on
the ground and your body rigid so you're
only pulling the weight of your upper
body you can perform this as a full row
and just make sure you are being
conscious to pinch the scapula behind
you at the top of the movement or you
can perform this as a scapular row Where
You're Gonna Keep Your Arms locked out
and simply shrug your traps backwards in
order to pull yourself upwards so you're
going to keep your arms straight and
it's just the movement of the scapula
that's going to move your body the upper
trap's a little bit harder to perform
with body weight but not impossible if
you're doing handstands handstand
push-ups a whole range of hand balancing
movements then you're often going to be
pushing vertically into the ground what
you want to do at the top of a handstand
is push into the ground with your arms
straight and of course this is
essentially an upside down shrug which
is why performing a lot of hand
balancing is a great way to actually
strengthen and increase the size of your
traps surprisingly this is a more
advanced movement if you perform it
against the wall maybe on some
parallettes or something it does make it
a lot more achievable
that then brings us to the lower traps
which we haven't discussed at all so far
you might be forgiven for thinking that
you don't need massively strong lower
traps because after all how often do you
need to push down with your shoulders
against resistance well there are a
couple of scenarios such as doing a
climb up in parkour if you're climbing a
wall or maybe during the top of a muscle
up however I get the point you're not
going to be doing it all that often but
that's not why you need to focus on
training your lower traps your lower
traps are important because they provide
balance and if you train your upper
traps and your mid-traps predominantly
and ignore the lower traps you can end
up with muscle imbalances that lead to
poor posture and a host of other health
issues so in this case if you're
training just your upper traps you've
got all this force and tension pulling
your shoulders upwards but you don't
have the relative necessary amount of
strength and tension at the bottom
pulling them back down into a nice
neutral position the result is you walk
around like this with your shoulders
around your ears and this isn't great
you might enjoy the look look a bit like
a gorilla but it's going to impede your
mobility and it's also going to cause
other issues too for example if you have
upper cross syndrome cathotic shoulders
because you're used to hunching forwards
then having just these big traps on top
of that ain't gonna help this can lead
you to walk around with your chin
sticking out which by the way inspiring
is a great way to get yourself knocked
out at the same time if you're up like
this it actually restricts your
breathing it can lead to mouth breathing
it can even elevate your stress response
your sympathetic response so that
throughout the day you're slightly more
stressed than you should be so don't
ignore the lower traps fortunately
they're once again a number of
calisthenics movements we can use to
train them really nice and easily
and a great option is the scapular dip
and here you're going to need a pair of
dip bars and all you're going to do is
you're going to dip as you normally
would but this time you're going to keep
your arms straight again and you're
going to Simply dip using your scapula
so shrugging up and down in Reverse in
order to push yourself up and down using
those lower traps like so
[Music]
and of course you can just perform this
movement using a regular dip and just
making sure once again that you use your
scapula and push yourself all the way
down at the top of the move also highly
effective are l-sits so he can be on the
ground on some parallettes or even some
push-up stands you're just going to push
through your shoulders keeping your arms
locked out so you raise your buttocks
off the floor and your feet are going to
be out in front of you try to keep the
toes pointed if you can it's also a
great Core workout great for compressive
strength it's a great all sorts of
things work out actually now performing
I'll sit on a set of parallettes or
push-up stands does make the movement
slightly easier it's absolutely fine but
if you perform it on the ground this is
actually better in some ways because
it's going to force you to really push
through the shoulders it's going to open
up a bunch of other movements as well
and if you can't do the l-sit to start
with then a great variation that is much
easier is the end sit you're just going
to bring your knees into your chest and
perform it the exact same way but it's
going to be a lot easier because you
have that weight out in front of you
so what do you think guys is this a
useful way of training your traps useful
way of thinking about your traps do you
think that the sandbag carries a low-key
awesome trap workout let me know your
favorites in the description down below
if you did enjoy this one then please
hit like and share it around it helps me
out immensely and please subscribe
that's the biggest thing you can do to
help the channel and if you didn't know
already I also have a patreon account if
you head to that in the link in the
description down below then you can get
early access to videos that have the
sponsor segments removed and there's
also a lively Community forming there
you'll have access to the exclusive
Facebook group and there's more coming
soon so yeah I'll leave a link and I
massively appreciate your support it
means the world to me but also
appreciate you just for watching so
thank you so much for watching this one
guys
and bye for now
by the way guys this video has been
sponsored by Squarespace a huge thank
you to Squarespace for making videos
like this possible and for being such
great supporters of the channel so
Squarespace is a website creation
platform that makes it extremely easy
for anyone to get started building their
own website it offers a host of
extremely customizable templates that
all look highly professional they're
responsive modern at the same time
though it also includes all the features
you could need to build out your website
to create something just as fully
featured as some of the biggest brands
on the web in fact many of the biggest
brands do use Squarespace for their
websites and just a few of those
features include Revenue generation
through gated members only content
publishing tools allow to format your
posts schedule them to publish later on
a fully integrated commenting system
with credit replies and likes member
management analytics and statistics
social media integration so that you can
have your social media sites post
directly to your page e-commerce
features you can sell products from your
site make even more money that way and
if you want to expand the features of
Squarespace even further then you can do
so by using one of the many plugins
available created by the community and
by Squarespace themselves for example if
you want to expand your eCommerce
solution then you can use plugins to do
things like track inventory handle your
accounting and tax reconciliation track
global Shipping really the sky's the
limit when it comes to Squarespace and
these plugins just allow you to take it
even further if you want to find out
more then head over to squarespace.com
and when you're ready to launch head to
squarespace.com forward slash bioneer
Link in the description down below and
you'll get 10 off of your first domain
or website thank you so much to
Squarespace again for sponsoring thank
you to you guys for watching and I'll
see you later
bye for now